this is actually a slide that i already
presented
last year in
a similar form
showing how
data
diversity in the data
and intelligent target language modeling
helps
a target language model in in a set of
these
of these models that i explained
the target language model helps us to
decide between the alternatives that we
have seen so you can easily use a target
language model to create a customized mt
system for specific terminology and
style
so what we did here is we used the
scibase which is a tda member
as an
as an example
and if you look at the right most blue
column here
so this is the test set
the the columns here each are a certain
test set this is the psi based test set
by tested i mean a set of parallel
sentences delivered by sideways within
tda
and test set is you data that's not used
for the actual training
of the engine
so
if you look here
a
cybase tested got a score of 34.81
with
our general system which is the the
system used at the bing translator
microsoft translator
then we translated it using a microsoft
trained system this is a
our system optimized for microsoft's own
use
the score is 29.95
interestingly it's worse than our
general system obviously cybers and
microsoft use very different terminology
in their product or in style at least in
chinese you can see that it's not the
case in german somehow cybers and
microsoft were more in agreement on
their style and terminology so using
microsoft system is much better than a
generic system
so you you customer you add more and
more data and you use a sideways
specific target language model you can
push the score up by uh
well by by uh 12 points here 13 points
which is very significant
right this way just by adding in domain
data with diversity we used all the
all the technical data within within tda
and using a site-based target language
model you get significant increases all
right
andrew talked a little bit about
cat
computer ada translation i want to
reverse it a little bit continuing the
thought from my three-minute speech
yesterday
let's think about moving
computer-aided translation and
post-editing use is still computer-aided
translation areas lisa as we talked
about today to human-a translation
machine translation is so good for many
cases today not
maybe not for every case but for so many
application scenarios it's good that we
can think of publishing material raw and
using a human to fix it up so what about
and maybe that answers a little bit
jessica's question so what's the merge
of of translation memory and machine
translation it is nicely and easily
mergeable whenever you have a
a human translation available you should
use it obviously and it should be
transparent with your whole translation
process we have that implemented here as
in
running a worldwide translation memory
which is
transparently available in a machine
translation service you just call our
service we will transparently use your
translation memory 100 match only uh
we'll we'll use that and if that's not
available we'll give you the
machine translation
so
using
api to feed that that translation memory
and the widget that we provide or that
you can program against yourself
you can fill that translation memory and
it'll be used you can do that in
real time after it has been published
let me talk a little bit about search
engine optimization in an experiment
that we did here
how
raw
machine translation
helps you gain a position in a search
engine
all right and as an as an example here i
use the the knowledge base i talk
frequently about the knowledge base
because it is in my views the
most advanced application of machine
translation at microsoft
the
uh so the the knowledge base uh up to
uh the beginning of this year was uh not
translated not not automatically
translated into czech but there were a
small number of of articles in fact two
and a half percent of articles were uh
human translated
so however the two and two and a half
percent covered fifty percent of the
page views right this was the most
important
articles
so over
over a couple of months the team
translated
a machine translated the remaining 97
and a half percent
so what's the
result in terms of in terms of page
views from users in the czech republic
this is measured here by referrals from
this check search engines that is says
nom.cc and google.css are the two
leading search engines in and in the
czech republic so if you look at so we
use that as representing the
uh
the visits by
people in the czech republic
all right so you can see here that this
uh doubled the the traffic
not not uh not surprisingly right at two
and a half percent gave you fifty
percent of page views doing the rest
gives you the remain remaining
uh uh fifty percent
uh so it uh it actually worked so you
attract the users to your site
and
you can
as a result you get more satisfied users
also out of it
how satisfied are the users with
with
machine translated content again the
knowledge base gives you a good
measurement because in every every
article it asks you did this help you
solve your problem and it's interesting
to compare
the resolve rate between
human translated articles and machine
translated articles and as you see here
the
the difference is not that
uh stock
obviously in most cases you get a better
resolve rate with human translated
articles
but
not so not so drastic so the blue the
blue bar is the resolve right on human
translated articles green is the resolve
rate on uh machine translated articles
so
i've i've watched this uh this uh this
over the years
the
it is really
consistent
it's always the same languages where the
data is small always the same languages
where the data is there is large
i conclude from that that
machine translation quality is not the
only determining
factor it's also the perception of
quality in the market that makes a
difference
for instance i know that that
the the
japanese
translation quality is really not that
not that bad compared to uh
compared to
other languages but
i can only use the cultural factors to
to explain that there is
a pretty drastic difference between the
human and machine translated articles
for korean as well here but i know our
korean engine is by far not as good as
the japanese for instance
you can also see that
the resolve that right overall
differs drastically between between
languages
english is somewhere somewhere in the
middle not at the top
okay
i hope that gives you a little insight
on how data is useful for machine
translation technology and also how
machine translation can help your
websites
your content to be distributed worldwide